Enough talk,
let's see this app in action.
I'll open up the Pirate Fleet xCode
project, and then I'll launch the app.
And as soon as the game launches, we
begin in the guessing phase as opposed
to when we actually get to place
our ships in our minds, and
that's something you'll do in code.
Now we've kept the UI pretty simple.
Here at the top,
we have the opponents grid.
And at the bottom we have our grid with
our ships in our minds that have already
been placed.
Now as I start guessing, I want you
to think about what objects and
relationships may exist
between the scenes.
So I'm going to start guessing, and
I have a little strategy in mind.
I'm going to try to
guess every two spaces,
because I feel like that will give me
a pretty good shot at hitting a ship.
Being that smallest ship's sized two.
So I hit a mine.
Hopefully I won't fall
too far behind here.
Got one ship.
And it looks like they're doing some
work on my big ships right now.
This, there we go.
All right I got the two
big ships out of the way.
Ooh, there we go.
Uh-oh, I think they might
all be lined up here.
If I have enough time,
I may be able to get all of them.
There we go!